all right hello there welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and uh as usual i'm happy to try and
answer
questions at
uh the question should be of uh
understandable by anybody
the answers can be as simple or
complicated as uh as they end up being
um kind of about any kind of science
technology mathematics and so on i'll
see what i can do
this is a fascinating exercise for me
because it's just a
look at the camera and see what i can
say about different kinds of things
all right we seem to have all kinds of
interesting questions here let's start
off with one from aaron
how closely are computer clocks
synchronized in different parts of the
world how do they synchronize
um
i don't fully know the answer to this
there is a thing called nnptp which is a
network um
a protocol for synchronizing clocks on
different computers
so okay how does how does a computer
clock basically work
there is usually a quartz crystal
oscillator that is a
a thing that is sort of an independent
clock that runs on every computer how
does it work
um what it is usually is a very tiny
crystal of quartz
that is being electrically
kind of um uh pushed in and out and it's
kind of oscillating and it has a certain
characteristic frequency on which it
oscillates kind of like if you have a
pendulum the pendulum depending on its
length will have a certain natural
frequency that it goes back and forth at
um and it's the same kind of idea when
you have this little piece of quartz
crystal which is uh electrically
stimulated and it goes back and forth at
a certain frequency
that kind of oscillator keeps time
reasonably accurately but it gradually
drifts
the only kind of way that we have of
keeping time that we think i was
perfectly accurate
is based on the properties of atoms
and a given atom has so-called spectral
lines
which are uh basically
well let me try i can try to explain
that
essentially
the um uh there is for any given atom of
a certain type like a cesium atom for
example cesium is a gas
one of the elements uh but it could be
oxygen atom anything else
uh any given type of atom
has as a certain
set of
frequencies of light that it produces
and it's a fixed discrete set of
frequencies and those frequencies can be
computed from quantum mechanics
and
for a given kind of atom it's always the
same so you have a certain cesium kind
of the cesium atom with a certain
isotope of cesium and if it sits there
it you know that a particular transition
a particular
kind of light that can be emitted when
the cesium atom goes from one energy
level to another will be a fixed
frequency always the same
okay so that is the way that the most
accurate atomic clocks that's kind of
the idea that they use
is
to use these uh these frequencies of of
emission of light um the the very
specific frequency of of of uh of light
that's emitted um actually they they use
they don't i think use visible light but
they use um uh they use the fact that
there are fixed energy levels fixed
frequencies that occur in particular
atoms
and that's the idea of atomic clocks
they were invented in the i think in
1950s or so
um and that's the way that the most
accurate time keeping is done because
uh and so what what can go wrong with an
atomic clock you've got a cesium atom it
has this particular frequency of
oscillation effectively this particular
transition frequency
the only thing that can go wrong is
things as a result of properties of
space time so for example if the cesium
atom is going at a high speed there will
be time dilation and that means that the
the effective rate of the clock running
will be slower than it would be at rest
that's one effect that's an effect
that's seen in the gps satellites for
example that have accurate timing in
them but the gps satellites are moving
rapidly in orbit around the earth and so
the effective rate of the clocks is
slightly slower than it would be on the
surface of the earth the second effect
is gravity
uh tends to let's see in a in a um
high gravitational field a clock will
run relative to
uh the running outside the clock will
run faster relative to the rate it runs
outside
um
and so again that's a phenomenon called
gravitational redshift
that
causes clocks to run at a different
speed when they're in in gravitational
fields actually in our theory of physics
we can give a pretty intuitive
explanation for this phenomenon of time
dilation
here's roughly how it works
the
when you think about a clock
made of atomic transitions or whatever
else it is
that clock in our theory of physics is
ultimately made of some huge number of
atoms of space that are all being
updated according to some computational
process
and the rate of updating according to
that computational process defines the
passage of time so if a certain number
of computational steps have been done
that corresponds to like the passage of
one second
okay so that's if a thing is just
sitting somewhere and it's just updating
itself after some number of updates it
will have a second of time will have
passed
now let's imagine that the thing is
moving at some speed it's got to it's
got to then it's got to do two things
it's got to update itself to to
represent the passage of time and it's
got to rearrange itself it's got to
reassemble itself at a different
position in space
because in our model of physics
all of the what the universe consists of
is just this giant collection of atoms
of space and connections between atoms
of space so when you have an object that
exists in one place it's made from some
complicated tangle of atoms of space
when it moves to another place what's
happening is that that complicated
tangle is getting reassembled in that
other place it's kind of like what
happens i don't know a wave on water
it's not that the individual molecules
of water are moving with the wave it's
that the effect of the wave is being is
being transported and new molecules are
taking on the shape of that wave and so
it is i think with everything in our
universe as i move my hand around or
whatever it's it's being recreated with
new atoms of space every time i move it
and so what happens to a clock
is
you can kind of have a trade-off the
clock has a certain amount of
computation that it's doing
and it can either use that computation
working out what it's what its future
will be evolving through time or it can
use that computation reassembling itself
in a different place in space
and so when you are moving in space
you're sort of using some of the
computation you would otherwise be using
to progress in time and so effectively
you run times slower because you're
using some of your computational effort
to move in space
and it's the same with gravitational
fields the presence of uh gravitational
fields are associated in our models with
essentially a higher density of updates
to this this to the network that
represents the universe and whether
where there's a higher density of
updates effectively time is is is
progressing more quickly and that's kind
of the intuitive explanation in our
model it's never been really been
possible to have an intuitive
explanation like that before of these
phenomena but that's sort of the
intuitive represent
explanation of the these um uh phenomena
of of the way that time is affected by
uh by velocity or by by gravity and so
on
okay so
the original question was asked about
synchronization on the internet
there is an atomic clock i believe it's
in uh colorado colorado springs maybe
maintained by the national bureau of
standards national institutes of
standards and technology nowadays
that is kind of the central clock that
is used to kind of define
uh sort of now for the internet then
there's this protocol an ntp
that distributes those now moments to
different computers and re-synchronizes
the quartz oscillator clocks on those
computers now it's a tricky business
because
how long does it take when the clock
says
it's now precisely noon
or this particular time in this
particular place
um how
how does one get
that information about when when that
happened
to clocks in different places around the
world here's why there's a problem the
problem is imagine that you sent a radio
signal well the radio signal will take a
certain amount of time to arrive because
the speed of light the speed of radio
waves it's only finite it's uh light
goes about 186 000 miles per second or
about uh
um in it goes in one billionth of a
second it goes about one foot
um so to get across the earth
uh so how do you get a signal across the
earth well a typical way you would do it
nowadays on the internet is with fiber
is through the backbone of the internet
it's mostly fiber optics which means
it's it's light
traveling in in glass
uh because that's what fibers glass
fibers of fiber optics are
and the refractive index is around 1.5 i
think what that means is that light goes
about one and a half times slower
in the fibers and the glass fibers than
it does in in free space
in a vacuum for example so that means
that the the uh the
sort of synchronization time is sort of
speed of light uh
uh
times 1.5
so it takes
at least tens of milliseconds if not uh
so 100th of a second to maybe even a
tenth of a second i'd have to do the
arithmetic to work out exactly how long
um to get a signal and and perhaps it
takes even longer because when you're
sending a signal through the internet
the signal may have to go through
repeaters so it may go through a stretch
of fiber that's uh a thousand miles long
going across the you know some some
ocean or something and then when it gets
to the other end the signal is goes into
a piece of electronics and that
electronics has to retransmit the signal
again and that might take another i
don't know a few milliseconds or
something
so in general
it could take it's not untypical for the
so-called ping times uh across the
internet to be half a second 500
milliseconds the ping time is the time
it takes uh if your computer sends
something to another computer uh saying
to the other computer uh hello are you
there
then there's a it is sending that signal
out through the internet and then it
gets a signal back from that other
computer saying oh yes hello i'm there
and and generally you know when you send
packets out on the internet these
different kinds of packets that get sent
out like for a website it's tcp packets
and for
uh for for um streaming video it's
usually i think udp packets that the
difference is like a tcp packet it has
the feature that that the the the web
server kind of knows it was received it
has a handshake it has a return
it it it gives information back that yes
it was returned whereas if you're
streaming a video out and a few packets
get lost well they get lost and you
don't really want to have that uh oh you
need to retransmit them and so on that's
a bad idea that part of the video has
already happened there's yet a different
kind of packet cmp packets i guess which
are the ones that are used for
uh for things like ping messages uh
where a computer is just saying to
another computer hello are you there
and anyway that that the typical ping
times across the whole internet are on
the order of hundreds of milliseconds so
okay so how then does the
synchronization work
well it's a little bit tricky and i'm
not sure i know all the details of it
but
you have a that sort of central clock
that's saying now it's noon and then you
have to be able to make sure that
another
that your computer which is
uh
let's say two tenths of a second away in
ping time from that
central clock that it knows when that
when that central clock said it was noon
even though it gets that signal 200
milliseconds later
and i believe the way that's done
is the sort of back and forth signals
which are used to try and compute what
that delay time is and correct for it
that's this confusing thing because one
of the features of relativity theory is
that one assumes that the maximum speed
of any
of any transmission is the speed of
light and that's kind of what leads to
the whole structure of relativity theory
but in a sense by saying oh we're going
to uh set this up so that we correct for
the transmission delay you're
essentially denying relativity theory
you're saying no actually we're going to
make it be as if we were transmitting
information instantaneously now the
reason why that there isn't anything
sort of wrong with that whether it
doesn't violate relativity theory is
that what's happening is it's just a
clock it's just saying now it's this
time now it's a second later now it's
two seconds later and so on and so you
can independently work out what the
clock is going to do if the clock was
generating the most creative sort of uh
i
it was it was generating its creative
poetry or something where you couldn't
readily predict what would come next
then this strategy of saying let's
correct for the transmission time and
let's make this seem like it happened at
the at the moment that corresponded to
that particular time won't work because
you won't be able to make that
prediction but because it's just a clock
you can make that prediction and you can
get things synchronized
it's um the infrastructure of the whole
uh synchronization the internet is is a
little bit rickety i would say it's not
as robust as it might be and it's fairly
important
um that it worked correctly because an
awful lot of things nowadays depend on
time comparisons like did this come in
before that thing did this
you know something like i don't know the
blockchain for example it's very big on
on what was the order in which these
things were put on the blockchain and
things like and what what was the
timestamp at which this occurred so it's
fairly important to maintain sort of the
global time of the internet
it's an interesting question when the
internet is is more widely used uh sort
of interplanetarily
how that will all work because the time
on mars for example might be 20 minutes
delayed relative to speed of light from
the time on earth the time on the moon
might be a second or two delayed
relative to time on earth when in the
sense that when you send that signal
it's like it will arrive it will the
speed of light is such that it will
arrive
say a second later or on mars 20 minutes
later or whatever else it is and
obviously on mars because it's orbit
it's um it's orbiting the sun like the
earth does and there's a
huge difference and if the mars is on
the opposite side of the sun from the
earth of the same side the distances are
very different and so the time delays
are different it's not so much for the
moon because it has a fixed distance
more or less from the earth
so there there are very tricky issues
about what on earth will be this
synchronized time uh when when there's a
mars colony in it and it's trying to
decide what it's uh what its time should
be and so on um that that's a that's a
tricky issue for um
for the future
all right let's see
oh boy there's another one from aaron
here
uh about scar tissue how does the body
know when to create scar tissue does the
body make different scar tissue based on
the tissue it's repairing
i don't completely know all the answers
to this
the um
uh what happens you know when blood
clots for example
it um so what what happens is there's a
a whole sort of chemical reaction that
starts to occur when sort of blood is
exposed to the outside air
and you get a cascade of things which i
think leads to this thing called
fibrinogen which is a a long
scraggly molecule that's that's kind of
long and gets tangled up and what starts
the process of clotting and what starts
to turn the liquid blood into something
which has this long polymer this long
molecule that um uh that sort of uh can
can knit things together i think
in um
the question of how
tissue regenerates itself
uh people study
different kinds of
critters like amphibians for example can
regrow limbs which we humans cannot
um and
there's sort of a whole question about
how that works and how does it know what
it should grow so to speak
and that that relates to the whole
question about how do things grow in the
first place
the um
there is a fair amount knowing about
that
the um uh actually okay so so
in a first approximation if you want to
know
uh kind of
what shape will something grow into how
is that kind of how is that defined in
the in the organism um you can see other
indications of of how things grow by
asking what pigmentation pattern gets
produced on the zebra or on the um
or on the mollusk shell or whatever else
it is
well the
the most common mechanism for defining
kind of how things grow
is the diffusion of small substances
i guess classically they get called
morphogens although there are particular
substances like retinoic acid for
example vitamin a is one of the ones
that's involved and what happens is
these are comparatively small molecules
and there will be a source of this
substance
somewhere in the in a growing
organism and
over that substance will diffuse a
certain distance
and it will it will then
and as the concentration of that
substance goes down
you'll you'll have something where
things grow until the concentration of
that substance goes below a particular
value and then things will stop growing
and that's kind of the typical way that
sort of the architecture of uh
well one one level of the way in which
the architecture of the organism gets
laid down so the most basic thing is you
have
sort of the the um the substances
emitted somewhere in the tissue and then
it kind of decays down as it gets
further away just by the process of
diffusion it's kind of like the
molecules are just doing random walks
and uh they they get to a certain
distance on average after a certain time
and so on the other effect is reaction
diffusion equations where you're having
this diffusion process and you actually
have multiple chemicals and they are
reacting with each other and there is a
characteristic set of patterns that you
get from this process of reaction and
diffusion and remarkably enough those
patterns look very much they are the
patterns of stripes and spots and things
that you often see on organisms those
are the result of essentially a reaction
diffusion process
together with something what leads to
discrete stripes for example on a zebra
is that although there is a continuous
variation of these particular substances
as you go across the zebra for example
the um
there are particular
processes that start up or shut down
depending on whether the concentration
is above some critical level or below
some critical level
there are some genes usually called the
homeobox or hox genes that are very much
related to this whole question of of
above a certain level of um
uh of concentration of these morphogens
then grow tissue and below that level
don't grow tissue and so that's kind of
the sort of the first approximation how
you start getting uh particular growth
patterns
um there are other kinds of things that
happen there's lots of kinds of places
where there's folding of of tissue that
gets produced where something will grow
out in a certain direction and then
we'll will sort of grow out so far that
it has to fold over uh there are other
places where you'll get um uh you know
every every piece of every organism kind
of had to grow to be that way and so
it's an interesting thing to kind of
catalog the different forms of growth
you know you have a horn that's growing
and for example one side of the horn at
the base the horn goes at the base of
the horn and one side of the base of the
horn may be growing faster than the
other and that means that side is going
to involve more tissue than the other
side and so the horn will curl over
because that the side that's growing
more will be longer than the side that's
growing less and so that will make the
horn go in a spiral eventually
and then there are all kinds of
different mechanisms like for example
our our fingers are produced by a kind
of flat uh uh plane of of tissue that
originally gets produced and then the
tissue in between the fingers dies
um so it's a it has sort of a program
cell death and that's how we go from
sort of having webbed webbed hands at
some early stage of fetal development to
having fingers and there are all these
different mechanisms that get used
but
this question of
if a piece of organism
is damaged how does it repair itself
these mechanisms of morphogens and so on
for us mammals i don't think operate
after fetal development whereas i think
for amphibians they are still operating
even in even in adulthood and obviously
if you're an amphibian you go from a
tadpole to being a frog there's all
kinds of dramatic uh kind of
rearrangement of tissue that's happening
in the process of doing that
so i think the um this question of how
how a piece of tissue
uh figures out that it should grow more
of a particular kind of tissue rather
than another kind this is this was a
long time mystery i think it's gradually
becoming clearer how that works
what are different kinds of tissues in
us
you know every cell in our bodies has
the same genetic code it has the same
dna in it it has the same set of
instructions for how to make
uh make the organism and the question is
why do some cells
become pieces of bone and some pieces of
muscle and some nerve cells and so on
this is the process of differentiation
in in biological organisms and
there have been
all sorts of theories for that i think
it's becoming a little bit clearer how
that works
and i think it's it's to do with um
uh sort of things outside of the genome
that are affecting which genes are
actually going to be expressed so what's
happening is you've got you know 6
billion base pairs maybe 30 000
different
genes each gene specifies make this kind
of protein make assemble these amino
acids into this molecule and they're 30
000 different kinds of molecules that
that uh we make actually more than that
but that's the number of genes um the
and the question in any particular cell
if you're a hair cell and you're making
a piece of you know keratin or something
then you need to be concentrating on on
having the the keratin genes be active
and producing producing protein from
that if you're a muscle cell they're
going to make actin filaments and then
those have to be the active things and
so on and so the question is what
switches on and off those different
genes those different pieces of protein
synthesis from the same dna program that
exists in all our cells
um and uh the the there's been sort of a
a long story of of trying to understand
how that works
the thing that can happen is
uh when you have a
okay so once you have a differentiated
cell the general thing is that once
you're a hair cell you're not going to
be able to produce cells even if you
replicate even if you divide the things
you divide into will also be let's say
hair cells or something you won't be
able to go back from having a hair cell
to having a heart tissue cell or
something um that was kind of the the
conventional wisdom about how things
work and if you imagine an organism like
us you know we start from a single cell
and then we divide and eventually we
have uh a few trillion cells and
each of those cells has a certain
lineage it has a it came from other
cells that were dividing we're dividing
we're dividing uh the maximum number of
sort of maximum depth of divisions is
about 50 um but our cells sort of divide
starting from this undifferentiated
beginning and then eventually uh divide
into some will be nerve cells some will
be will be uh you know muscle cells etc
etc etc that sort of plan that process
of differentiation there's a whole kind
of chart i think still incompletely
known for humans about exactly how all
these different types of cells these
some number of hundreds of types of
cells may be more than that maybe it's
thousands some how these different types
of cells all arise in the kind of
lineage in the in the genealogy of cells
in the human and so that's that's some
uh and this process of how does it
differentiate how do you how do you get
from one kind of cell and how does it
start turning into another kind of cell
and then you can't go back is the
general point of view
now there is this notion of stem cells
which are so called pluripotent stem
cells stem cells that have all the power
to do anything the power to turn into
any kind of cell and people had thought
back i know 20 years ago or more that
only in at the fetal level
do you have stem cells that are capable
of turning into anything but then people
figured out how to take sort of any old
cell
and turn it into more or less any old
cell and turn it back into a cell that
was capable of differentiating into
anything and that's an important idea
for trying to do things where you will
reconstruct some tissue by saying let's
take one of your cells maybe it's even a
skin cell or something turn it back into
a stem cell and then have it
differentiate again and turn into a
pancreatic cell or turn into a heart
muscle cell or something like this
um but that's um
uh but the question of of how uh you get
there from here with how the how
how a cell that is sort of embedded in
an existing uh organ manages to know
that it should be of that organ it's
presumably the result of these kind of
diffusion processes these these same
kinds of things like morphogens but i
don't know exactly how that works and
i'm not sure it's known how that works
ah okay let's see
um
let's see your questions here about
oh boy all kinds of interesting ones all
right there's a fairly simple one here
from roku
asking what is the meaning of light
years
so that's pretty simple
one light year is the distance light
goes in a vacuum in one year
and
so
light goes
uh in a in a billionth of a second light
goes a foot
so that tells you
that um and there are
a useful fact to know there are about 30
million seconds in a year
so that gives you um that will tell you
it's um uh about um
uh 30 million billion feet
is how far light goes in a year
so for example the sun
is about eight light minutes away from
the earth that means that it takes light
about eight minutes to go the 93 million
miles to the sun
it takes light about four years to go
from the earth to alpha centauri the
nearest star other than the sun
um so light years are just a measure of
the of the distance of distance how far
does light go in a year how big is the
universe in light years um
well let's see i i always remember these
particular numbers and i have to do a
little bit of calculation to figure out
um how this works so here's the here's
the calculation i would i would do
um
the uh let's see light goes
um
three times ten to the eight three
hundred million meters per second
and there are three times ten to the
seven uh seconds in a year so that means
that the um
uh
that's 10 to the 16 meters
is one light year uh just doing that
multiplication three times ten to the
seven times three times 10 to the 8. if
i got that right boy i used to be so bad
at arithmetic when i was younger um i
now relative to the rest of the world i
seem to be either i've gotten better
which i don't think i necessarily have
or the rest of the world has gotten
worse but but if i'm not mistaken uh
with 3 times 10 to the 8 times 3 times
10 to the 7 you add the exponents that's
10 to the 15 and the 3 times 3 is
roughly 10 so that's about 10 to the 16
meters
for a light year
and so
the universe is about 10 to the 26
meters that's a one with 26 zeros after
it
meters across and so that means that the
universe would be about um
uh in would be 10 to the uh would be
about some 10 billion light years across
um so that that gives uh some some sense
of um
of that
um
okay let's
see uh
it's a question here from baker about
can i say anything about this year's
nobel prize on complex systems any
relationship to what we're doing i
suspect you're referring to giorgio
parisi uh who's somebody i i've known
not terribly well for many years a
physicist who who won the nobel prize
this year he's a very fine physicist
um i think the um uh i have to admit i
haven't read the the precise description
of of uh what the prize is for but one
thing that giorgio parisi has worked on
a lot of things called spin glasses i
can at least tell you what spin glasses
are and how they work
so
okay first first comment is uh well spin
glasses are uh emerge from from a study
of
uh how things like magnetism work
in things like crystals
so
back in the 1920s
people were trying to figure out when
you have a block of iron and it's
magnetized how does that work
and
what what happens is there are these
basically atoms in the iron that are
like little tiny bar magnets
and the question is do they line up or
do they not line up
and when the iron bar is magnetized
what's happened is that all those tiny
little bar magnets associated with each
different atom they're all lined up
if you heat up the block of iron you
eventually get to the the curie
temperature which i'm not sure that was
named after pierre curie or marie curie
um but anyway maybe pierre curie in that
particular case um the husband of marie
curie um the uh
anyway the curie temperature is the
temperature at which
uh
and a
block of the curing temperature for iron
for example is the temperature at which
all those atoms even if they were lined
up originally
you'll destroy the magnetism of that
thing that there will be no net
magnetism in that thing
um and that uh
and that so if you take your your magnet
and you
you heat it up eventually it will lose
its magnetism and that happens at a
suddenly at a particular temperature
just like suddenly at a particular
temperature water will boil or ice
where all the all the molecules of water
are all nicely lined up in a crystal ice
will melt and the molecules will just
sort of be freely floating around in a
liquid it's the same kind of thing with
magnetism there'll be a critical
temperature at which the instead of all
these magnets being lined up they're
sort of all randomly arranged
okay why do the magnets line up the
reason the magnets line up is because
when you have two bar magnets and
they're very close to each other there
is a tendency for those bar magnets to
line themselves up for north poles to
line with north poles south poles with
south poles if the magnets are sort of
close enough together and if there isn't
too much
kicking around from heat
then the magnets will tend to be lined
up
and there was a description of that that
was um
invented it's thing called the ising
model is ing
um the uh
actually invented by a
guy called lens eisen was a student who
worked out the details of of how this
model works um but the model just says
you have these spins these these
ways of making atomic magnets and
they have a certain if they're lined up
if two of them next to each other are
lined up
they have a lower energy they are
they're basically they want to be lined
up if you if you put them the opposite
way around they they will want to flip
around and and go to that lower energy
state
so
the izing model is this mathematical
model that describes uh that gives
assigns a sort of energy to any
particular configuration of of the spins
of atoms
and it was then worked out that when the
temperature is low enough when there's
very little randomness when there's a
little randomization in those
orientations of those of those spins
then they will all tend to line up and
you'll get magnetism because magnetism
comes because all those little tiny
atomic bar magnets are all lined up
okay so that was the theory of
of
ferromagnetism standard kind of
magnetism that exists in a block of iron
or a rare earth magnet like a galilean
block of gadolinium or something like
this
there are other phenomena like another
phenomenon is so-called
anti-ferromagnetism
where instead of all the
all the atoms being lined up they're
alternately
lined one way and lined the opposite way
that's a different different case
and so there's a there's a different a
variant of the izing model which
describes anti-ferromagnetic materials
rather than ferromagnetic materials and
it has a slightly different energy
function that describes what the energy
associated with neighboring spins being
in different configurations is
okay so that's the story of the ising
model so the the the ising model
has the feature that at a given
below a certain temperature
the ground state the lowest energy state
will consist of all of the all of the
spins being lined up in other words
overall magnetism
ferromagnetism okay so then sometime
when was it probably the 1950s 1960s
people started looking at materials that
weren't as well organized as just having
all these spins all lined up
like in a crystal for example and being
able to compute to be saying that the
energy between these spins over here was
the same as the energy of the two in the
spins over here
instead they looked at spin glasses okay
what is a glass
so in a crystal the defining
characteristic of a crystal is that the
atoms are all lined up in a very
organized way so for example in a salt
crystal sodium chloride it's a cubic
lattice
so the the roughly the the sodium and
chlorine atoms are arranged on uh
in particular places with respect to
cubes so it's this giant sort of cubic
array of atoms um that make
a salt crystal and even the outside of a
salt crystal will tend to be a cube
because the atoms are just arranged in a
cubic fashion in the salt crystal so
that's a crystal is something where the
atoms are arranged in extremely regular
way and there are limited number of
possible arrangements that atoms can
have in crystals
okay a glass
is a solid material but where the atoms
are not arranged in a regular way like
that the atom's just sort of thrown
together it's like in a giant ball pit
of atoms where all the atoms are just
sort of randomly arranged
um that is how what what the arrangement
of a glass is
uh actual glasses is silicate silicon uh
with with the atoms sort of arranged
randomly like that
so when you have the atoms arranged
randomly like that it's no longer the
case that you can say that the uh the
sort of if you if you had magnetic spins
at each of those places it would no
longer be true that
the um
uh that things would line themselves up
the atoms are not all lined up the
energy functions associated with these
magnets neighboring magnets in one part
of the material wouldn't be the same as
the energy functions associated with
with neighboring spins in a different
part of the material instead it will be
this much more random arrangement of oh
in this place it's good to have these
spins lined up in this other place it's
good to have the spins be anti-parallel
and so on and in general you could you
have this kind of random energy function
in different places around the material
reflecting the fact that the material
itself is not a nice lined up crystal
it's an amorphous material a glassy
material
so what a spin glass is
is something where all those energy
functions are kind of randomly picked at
different places in the spin glass it's
not the case that all of the energy
functions are all of the things are all
the same so that the thing is just a
regular thing where there's just a bunch
of ferromagnetism so then the question
is okay if you look at a system like
that
and you look at it at low temperatures
for example what what arrangement will
those spins actually take on
and and how will they how will they be
arranged well that's a hard thing to
know
and one of the things that can happen is
that you end up with a very large number
of different completely different
configurations of these spins that all
have the property that they have about
the same energy so you have a a very
large number of possible states of the
system whereas in an ordinary
ferromagnetic magnet the lowest energy
state is always all spins are all lined
up
um for a spin glass there may be lots of
different states with lots of very
different complicated arrangements of
spins that may all be yes this will be
the lowest energy state so now you might
ask the question well if you take an
actual spin glass material you've got it
heated up you cool it down
what actual configuration will it take
on of those infinite number of possible
low energy configurations which one will
actually take on
and that's a complicated question and
it's a little bit like if you are a
mountainscape or something and you're
rolling a marble let's say you have a
model mountain scape and you're rolling
a marble down the mountainscape and you
ask in which valley will that mount will
that marble end up well it depends you
know if it started rolling this way it
may go to that mount it may go to that
valley let's say there's a crater in
your mountainscape the marble may get
stuck in that crater even though there
was a much lower valley somewhere else
there may be a hill between that crater
and the lowest valley and that marble
may never get out of that it may never
go down to the lowest valley and so
that's the thing that can happen in spin
glasses there are many meta-stable
states there are many local minima
places where the the configuration of
the spin glass gets stuck and it can't
reach the the true minimum energy state
um so typically
that's a problem that happens in a lot
of situations where you've got this kind
of the analog of a mountainscape and
you're trying to find where's the
absolute lowest point on this landscape
how do you get there and the usual
strategy so-called gradient descent
where you just say from wherever you are
follow the path that takes you the most
quickly down the mountain so to speak
well that strategy will often not work
and you'll just end up getting stuck in
some local minimum in some place where
there is a path if you if you could find
the right way to go you'll be able to
get down to a much lower energy
configuration much lower place on the
mountain but you can't by just using
that strategy of always go down the
steepest the path of steepest descent
you won't be able to get there so the
various tricks people invented there's
one trick called simulated annealing
where basically what happens is you let
things you kind of imagine going down
the mountain you know always in the the
steepest path
and then you add some random noise you
add some temperature you kind of
imagine it's a marble the marble is just
rolling down but then you shake
everything and then so you shake the
marble out of that local minimum and
then it will tend to go to a lower
minimum and get to something which is a
better configuration it's a little bit
analogous if you have a bunch of let's
say uh balls uh or let's say you have
coffee beans and you say are you going
to be able to get these coffee beans to
pack in the best possible way well for
spheres okay for circles you just take a
bunch of coins and you push them
together the coins will take on a
hexagonal configuration as soon as you
push them together for spheres there is
a closest packing the so-called kepler
packing where you just arrange spheres
in this particular way that people tend
to arrange spherical fruit and grocery
stores there is an arrangement that is
the closest packing which finally proved
to be the closest packing
a decade or two ago
after
many hundreds of years of people
assuming it was but not knowing for sure
but anyway that particular packing if
you just take a bunch of spheres
a bunch of balls you kind of push them
together that's not the packing you'll
get into you'll get into a packing where
things have lots of holes and and they
just you can't just by pushing pushing
pushing on the sides things will just be
stuck and you'll never get to that
lowest configuration it's very similar
to the marble just gets stuck in that
local minimum and never goes to the
global minimum
so in fact that's why when people are
trying to i don't know pack coffee beans
and so on they'll they'll you know
they'll bang them because that's sort of
that's like simulated kneeling that's
kind of like randomizing them again so
that they don't get stuck in those local
minima and they can get closer to this
closest packing idea
so anyway in in a spin glass
you get these all these local minima you
get all these kind of almost lowest
energy states and so on and it turns out
one of the phenomena that happens is
that if you ask the question what kind
of a mathematical problem is it to find
the minimum configuration of a spin
glass it turns out it's a mathematical
problem so-called np-complete problem
which is equivalent to lots of other
mathematical problems so another another
example of a problem that it's
equivalent to is the so-called traveling
salesman problem so imagine that you
have a bunch of cities let's say i don't
know all the capital cities in europe or
something or all the capitals of the u.s
states and let's imagine that you're
going to fly a plane between all those
capital cities the question is in which
order should you visit those capital
cities in order to end up having the
minimum total distance of plane uh plane
distance flowing and that turns out to
be a difficult problem you can clearly
answer the question by trying all
possible arrangements of those cities so
if there are n cities there's n
factorial arrangements so let's say
there were 100 cities there'd be about
100 to the power 100 um different
possible con possible orderings of the
um
of of which which order you could visit
those cities in that's an absurdly large
number and the question is can you in
practice find a faster way to get to the
thing which is the best the shortest
path that problem turns out to be
equivalent to the problem of finding the
ground state the lowest energy state of
a spin glass
um by the way as a practical matter like
in morphing language we have very
efficient algorithms for solving a
traveling salesman problem and even
though probably in principle there is
some configuration of cities where it
would take this sort of exponentially
long time to find the answer in practice
it can usually be done rather quickly
using the kinds of algorithms that we
have
it's a sort of typical feature how that
plays into things like spin glasses of
you know can you find a good minimum
usually quickly even though the official
sort of lowest point is really hard to
find that's a complicated question i
think improperly worked out at this time
and in general the question so spin
glasses are this sort of random
arrangement of of energies and asking
the question how does how does that um
uh you know what what kind of uh energy
minimum do you get there uh there's
other kinds of problems even if if you
even take the izing model the original
ferromagnetic model and instead of
saying that i mentioned there's both
ferromagnetic cases where two spins want
to be aligned and the anti-ferromagnetic
cases where they want to be anti-aligned
even if you make that a little bit more
complicated and you say this little
template that says around this place i
want my northeast neighbor to be up my
southwest neighbor to be down et cetera
et cetera et cetera you make a slightly
complicated template of what you want
even in a case like that it can be very
hard to figure out what the ground state
of the system is it's sort of an
interesting problem i've been hoping
somebody's going to solve this for years
it turns out that problem i mentioned
that the these problems about spring
glasses are equivalent to a traveling
salesman problem another problem that
this stuff is equivalent to is the
problem of tiling so you can ask the
question given you have these tiles of
particular shapes or more to the point
let's say you have square tiles and the
tiles have colored edges and you say i
want my tiling to be such that the red
edges always line up for these tiles and
the green edges line up and so on you
try and make an arrangement of tiles
that covers the plane you might say well
it'll be straightforward to do that if i
if i see these tiles i'll be able to
just say oh i can line them up this way
i can do the jigsaw puzzle this way it
turns out that that problem is very hard
it turns out that's another one of these
to know
whether
you can tile a region just a size a
particular size region a size n region
let's say
is something which can be exponentially
hard um and so you can imagine well how
do you tell whether you can tile it
where you just try all the possibilities
you try this kind of tile here then this
one here then this one here and so on
you try all the possibilities
well that one of the issues with tiling
is this let's say that you're you're
trying to figure out can you tile
something with these particular set of
tiles
well you you tile something in some
particular region it can be really
difficult to figure out whether it can
tile in that region you might have to
try all these possibilities but then let
me make it even harder let me ask the
question can you tile the whole plane
the infinite plane can you tile will
this tiling just go on to infinity will
it will it will it arrange will there be
an arrangement that uh successfully
satisfies the constraints of the tiling
going off to infinity so that problem is
so-called as a so-called undecidable
problem it's a problem where you can't
guarantee that a computer in a finite
time could ever answer that question
clearly if you just think about actually
doing the tiling or trying all the
possibilities even worse but just doing
it you can say well let's start tiling
and we keep going and we've tiled the
size hundred region now we've tiled the
size a thousand region can we go can we
keep going to the size ten thousand
region or will it be the case that at
the size a hundred thousand regions
suddenly we get stuck and we can't tile
any further
what is known is that in principle you
can end up tiling arbitrarily far to the
million million millionth size region
and then oops you're stuck there's no
upper bound there's no limit on how far
you might have to go to know whether
you're going to get stuck
in practice actually i've been actually
rather recently looking for looking at
some of these tilings where it can be
the case that there is a very simple set
of constraints on the tiling but where
the only way to tile is with some ran
random looking arrangement of tiles
it's something i had found back in the
1990s i had found some examples where
you could end up being forced to have
not a periodic kind of crystalline like
tiling but a kind of nested fractal-like
tiling as a way to tile the plane that's
also how things like penrose tiles work
although they have different shapes
rather than different matching
conditions for the tiles but that's a
case in a spin glass or even in one of
these sort of junior spin glasses where
things aren't sort of randomly arranged
but where you have these definite kind
of templates for different uh different
spins one of the things that happens is
the problem of finding the ground state
of a system like that is equivalent to
the problem of tiling an infinite plane
and that problem is undecidable so what
that means is for a computer to figure
out what is that ground state what is
that lowest energy configuration could
be arbitrarily difficult
so so one one place where that's
interesting is if you have a physical
system we just say i'm going to cool it
down and see what state it goes into
well maybe you can actually use that as
a computer
as a way to to do a pretty efficient
piece of computation because we know if
we're doing it from the computational
side that takes a lot of computational
effort in fact one of the strategies for
making quantum computers is based on
this kind of annealing idea um the spin
glass annealing idea um and it's it's so
what you do is you sort of encode a
particular let's say traveling salesman
problem or something like that
in the arrangement of of the sort of of
the of the weights of the of the um just
the particular energy functions for
different parts of this spin glass thing
and then you say okay let me actually
get this this arranged thing and let me
put it in liquid helium or something
make it very cold see what arrangement
it takes on
it won't
really solve the problem i suspect any
faster than you could by just doing the
computation but it's still as a
practical you know principle it won't do
that but as a practical matter it might
be an efficient way to find find results
and by the way this question of sort of
what's the minimum energy configuration
of things is also essentially the
question that you run into in the
training of neural nets in machine
learning and so on
let's see so that was a
uh
a little bit of description about spin
glasses
um
there was a question here
let's see oh
there's a question how do messenger
pigeons find their destination
well there's some amusing theories about
this
the question is
if
so i remember
from years ago a study that actually
says pigeons actually follow roads to a
large extent
or at least to some extent they have
kind of a a pattern of terrain that
they're looking for and it might include
roads they don't read the road signs i
think um but
the
um i remember many years ago i was
learning to fly small airplanes i
haven't done it in years and years and
years but but this was in a in an
earlier time and one of the solutions
for if you're completely lost
is fly down low enough that you can read
the freeway signs and that's a way to
find out where you are um i don't think
pigeons do that because i don't think
they can read
but um i think that the the sort of
pattern of roads is thought to have a
relationship to how pigeons find terrain
and so on
now the um
the other thing pigeons are able to do
is
they can
sense the earth's magnetic field just
like if you have an old-fashioned
compass
which has a magnet and the magnet the
the north pole of the bar magnet points
towards the earth's north magnetic pole
somewhere up in northern canada
um the um
the that's
the um uh
you can
navigate you can know which way is north
on the earth by looking at the earth's
magnetic field
but
your average
um
critter
doesn't have a way it doesn't have a
little compass in it doesn't have
anything magnetic in it we don't have
anything in us that is magnetic so far
as i know
and um uh so there's nothing that's sort
of going to be kind of
at least a first approximation there's
nothing that would kind of
turn around like a bar magnet does to
show you which way is north and magnetic
field
okay but pigeons may very well have a
mechanism in their brains
that can in fact detect magnetic fields
and it's a rather subtle mechanism that
makes use of of very detailed quantum
effects
in and it actually is making use of the
this notion of atomic spins that i
mentioned in connection with
ferromagnetism that they essentially
have
the thought is that they have some
molecules in which there is a
an atom
that has a spin that will tend to be
aligned or not with the earth's magnetic
field so for example when we have
proteins
proteins are what we're mostly made of
other than water and so on proteins are
these arrangements of amino acids just
these sequences of amino acids defined
by our dna and but proteins those amino
acids
contain hydrogen and and carbon and
oxygen and nitrogen i think phosphorus
and sulfur but that's about it
so if you want to have a piece of iron
in your body or a piece of cobalt or
some other element in your body or piece
of iodine
you don't get to have that made
in a protein a protein itself just
consists of these amino acids there are
20 kinds of amino acids they each have
this different arrangement of atoms but
they're all very they're all just atoms
of those particular kinds of of chemical
elements so in order to have something
like hemoglobin the uh the substance in
our red blood cells that allows us to to
capture oxygen transported around the
body in order to have something like
hemoglobin you have to have a protein
that somehow has to wind up with an iron
atom in it and the way it does that is
that it makes the kind of cage the
protein the other kinds of of atoms make
a kind of cage that's exactly the right
size to fit an iron uh
an iron atom into and so then just sort
of there's enough iron kind of floating
around that whenever there's an iron
atom that kind of gets near the piece of
hemoglobin up it goes in the hemoglobin
and gets stuck in that cage
and and we have the same mechanism for
example in the thyroid gland using that
for iodine for example vitamin b12
is is has cobalt in it um same kind of
mechanism this kind of caging an atom of
a different type so i think the way
pigeons do it
is they have a cage i'm not sure what
kind of atom is maybe maybe iron i'm not
sure maybe cobalt i'm i'm not sure one
of one of the uh one of the
atoms that has a um a large uh so iron
cobalt nickel are the three elements
that have uh
that act whose atoms act like bar
magnets the three most common elements
where the atoms act kind of like little
bar magnets and there are other elements
the rare earth magnets galileum europium
sumerium i forget the others um galinium
is the most common one those are even
more intense magnets because their atoms
have an even larger little bar magnetic
uh
act like
stronger bar magnets but so the idea i
think is that in pigeons that the the
theory is that sort of this cage this
this atomic scale cage that has an atom
and that atom tends to get lined up with
this magnetic field and the properties
of that somehow that
that that protein
has different configurations depending
on the arrangement of that atom inside
and that's a phenomenon associated with
quantum mechanics that that can happen
and it's a place where potentially
one is effectively seeing the effect of
quantum mechanics in the uh in the sort
of the magnetic sensitivity of the
brains of pigeons now it's an
interesting question if it works big
time for pigeons does it work smaller
time for us humans and is there a
possibility that us humans are actually
sensitive to magnetic fields even in a
small way and i have to say that for me
personally i i am
uh i have
in the past often found if ever i touch
a strong magnet i get this weird
tingling in my fingers that's such a
strange thing and i've tried to make
sort of a scientific study of this
phenomenon actually my my children have
tried experimenting on me in various
ways and the experiments are rather
inconclusive um it's not impossible that
electrochemistry of nerve cells can can
be sensitive to magnetic fields but it's
a little odd um and uh i think um but so
so i think the
one still doesn't know whether humans
how sensitive different aspects of
humans are to magnetic fields but
pigeons do seem to have a way to sense
the earth's magnetic field which helps
them in in finding their way when
they're not just following the roads and
so on
huh
well there's a question from asa here
how to fix dizziness on a boat
oh you know it's a funny thing i mean i
uh what is car sickness why does it
happen what is what is motion sickness
in general there are different kinds of
motion sickness the different kinds of
motion
for example in a there there's in in
three dimensions there's there's
basically three kinds of motion rolling
rolling twisting around like this
pitching up um you know uh sort of front
to back and yawing
going side to side
and those those different kinds of
motion
are characteristically different in
different
kinds of
transportation like cars i think are
mostly rolling motion
i think
boats are mostly pitching i think and
airplanes are mostly yawing
um and and i think that the so the first
question is
how do we why why do we even get motion
sick what what's going on well first
question is how do we know which way is
up how do we know
how we know how we're moving well one
way we know how we're moving is because
we can see the the horizon we can see
the scenery and we can see oh the
scenery is moving around in this or that
way and so our brain can figure out okay
if the scenery is moving that way that
means we must be moving sort of the
opposite way so to speak that's one way
that we know kind of which way is up and
how we're moving but we have another
mechanism for knowing it and it's the
confusion between these mechanisms that
causes motion sickness that other
mechanism is inside our inner ear there
is this arrangement of this the
so-called labyrinth so it's an
arrangement of three uh tubes
all at 90 degrees and they they're three
tubes arranged the
circular tubes and those circular tubes
contain little tiny uh sort of calcified
things called ooleths
um like nice word and these the ewell is
so like little tiny rocks and as you
move around as you move those
gravity will make or acceleration will
make those
move around in these in these um
semi-circular uh
canals in this in this labyrinth
and so what happens is
that as you turn your head as you tip
your head
you end up with those little
tiny tiny rock-like things just dropping
as a result of gravity in a particular
direction and because you have these
three different
uh different um uh
circular things at 90 degrees to each
other you get to see in sort of x y and
z coordinates you're getting to see
which way are you moving okay so how is
the motion of the head of the um of the
ooleth detected the answer is there are
hair cells um that line the edges of
that semicircular of that canal and as
that little rock moves it's it's sort of
pokey it's it's pushing its way through
those hair cells
and what happens is it's the same
mechanism as in our inner ear there are
hair cells and those hair cells have the
property that they have as they are
mechanically bent that generates a
voltage an electric electrical signal
and that electrical signal is then
passed to a nerve and then it goes in
the case of of of hearing in our ear it
goes the auditory cortex
in the case of uh balance in the case of
of this uh of this sort of motion of i
mean by the way it's worth remembering
that biology tends to use take one idea
and use it in lots of places so this
idea of have a hair cell and
detect when the hair cell is deformed it
uses that both in our ear for hearing
sound and then another thing in our ear
in this labyrinth in the semicircular
canals for hearing um for for detecting
uh orientation of of of the um of one's
head
and so what tends to happen is the the
the cause of motion sickness is that the
signals going to one's brain from the
motion of these oolitts don't agree with
the signals going to your brain from
what you see with your eyes
and so your brain kind of gets confused
and the way it signals that to you
is well how can it signal that to you it
doesn't uh it's hard for it's to have a
way to form the thought oh i'm moving in
an awkward way so it just makes you feel
uh feel sick in some way um and that um
and that's kind of the uh
that seems to be the origin of motion
sickness
um is that is that mismatch and i think
the uh depending on
uh you know when you get labyrinthitis
for example when you get an infection uh
that causes inflammation in those canals
that can prevent the oohless moving
through and then you can have a loss of
your sense of balance and you can be
very confused another thing that can
happen is those can just get stuck in
some configuration and there's this
absolutely bizarre medical
thing
that um i i've done it once it's just
the bizarrest thing because it's bizarre
because it works
and and the bizarre thing
is that
you
uh the question is can you unstick the
ooh lift that is stuck in the wrong
place in your in this canal in your
inner ear and the answer is well yes you
can you just put your head in this
direction that direction that direction
in this strange sequence of motions that
just unsticks based on the actual
geometry of what's happening in your
inner ear can just unstick the thing
that got stuck in the wrong place
and what is it called it's
something or other maneuver oh my gosh
what's it called um anyway it's it's
always it's always one of those things
where you kind of look at the diagram at
least for me you look at the diagram and
it's like you do this you do this you do
this
really and you know how could something
like this possibly work and it's like
you've been you know it's been you've
been having uh you know balance issues
and then you do this and then oh it's
all solved in a few seconds it's just
one of the strangest things it's kind of
like a a bug in us as a medical system
that happens to be a very easy bug to
fix
anyway the the basic cause of motion
sickness is this mismatch between sort
of the signals from your balance organ
and the signals from your eyes
now what can you do about that you know
i found personally uh i've been curious
for a long time how i can sort of deal
with this and i i am
uh usually when you're driving a car
yourself for example you get less motion
sick because you are actually your eyes
are actually looking at the scenery and
you're not you know it's not you're not
sort of getting confused based on little
pieces of scenery um mismatching with
what what your ears are telling what
your your balance organ is telling you
but you know i i got these weird uh
kinds of glasses that um i i found at
some probably at the consumer
electronics show one year which are
these these strange glasses that look
totally ridiculous but but um that have
kind of fluid in them
and on the on the sides of one's uh in
one's peripheral vision and the fluid
always is just because of the way that
that fluid level works they're always
that it's always uh it's always in in
the sort of parallel to the um uh it
always is like at sea level so to speak
it's always it's always oriented so that
it's it's it's flat so to speak so if
you if you turn your head that fluid
will sort of tip down in these glasses
and the idea is to give you a sense that
the uh that sort of the ground is really
oriented in the same way that gravity
and acceleration and orientation of your
head goes and so that's one possible
scheme for sort of un
uh for sort of unconfusing motion
sickness and seemed to work fairly well
for me i discovered another scheme is
and this is i think these are very
personal idiosyncratic kinds of things
you know i found if i'm if i'm listening
to music which i don't usually do but uh
with headphones and things then that's
another way that reduces motion sickness
for me
and um
a third thing that people often claim is
that there are these um uh if you if you
wear these things on your wrist how
could that have any effect on motion
sickness but it is a it is a feature of
our brains you know what what is our
nervous system doing when we have a lot
of sensors on our skin
um that uh uh that are figuring out you
know are we are we touching something
with our finger you know oh yes there's
there's sensors in our finger that go to
our brain that tell us yes we're
touching something there we have all
these different sensors and our brain
has to make sense of all this different
data that's coming in about what's
happening from these different nerves
and when we sense pain for example
that's a place where there's some
receptor that's saying typically that
saying something bad is happening here
tell the brain something bad is
happening and uh we and that is
perceived by us as some kind of pain
so
that and that can happen when there's
like tissue damage or some or some
pressure somewhere or whatever else
so so anyway that then
um the the question is can we with all
of these signals coming in from all of
our nerves
can we somehow confuse the brain or
reorient how the brain
is receiving those signals and so there
are all these techniques like
acupuncture that involves sort of
putting needles in that
that um activate nerves and these things
where you have sort of pressure in some
place that activates nerves and it's
it's a
there's kind of a
lot of um some science and a lot of kind
of uh experience and and folk medicine
and so on that's gone into figuring out
these questions about uh how can you
kind of confuse the nervous system to
the point where you conclude something
different like you're ignoring the the
signal from your ears because you're
getting the signal from this from this
pressure in your wrist or something and
it's very weird that something like that
would be possible but
all these nerves come into very similar
areas of the brain and there's sort of
an issue of how is the brain
interpreting those things and so you can
potentially sort of scramble its
interpretation or unscramble its
interpretation depending on how you're
looking at it by doing those kinds of
things although it's it's one of these
things where i suspect it kind of works
for some people doesn't work for other
people hard to know why what's going on
uh difficult to sort of unravel what's
happening
let's see
um
we should probably wrap up
soon
um
let's see whether
ha
a question from aaron was i ever bitten
by a pigeon as a child i don't believe
so
don't know
um
oh there's a question for me is there
difference in accuracy in the sensing
magnetic field depending on whether
there's just one bird or many flying
together
um the sensing magnetic field i think is
very much a one brain of one bird type
effect the whole question of birds
flying together on formation is a very
interesting and complicated question i
mean the birds can fly close enough that
they're actually using the wingtip
vortices so when they're when they're
flapping their wings and so on in
general when they're getting lift to um
uh to keep them keep them uh flying uh
they're generating vortices in the air
they're generating they're making the
air sort of spin around in a spiral
behind the behind the tips of their
wings and that having that air spinning
around a spiral means that it becomes
easier for the for the guy the bird
behind you um to to fly and so birds
often make use of that kind of um uh
that in when they fly in formation the
question of of how do they decide what
formation do they fly in you know you
see these kind of v-shaped formations
and things
and um i have to say i'm reminded of a
long time ago when i was researching
some things for my um big book new kind
of science
um the uh
uh
uh
just just a funny story here but but um
you know they're these v-shaped
configurations that geese and things
like that tend to make where there's one
leading goose
at the front and then there's a kind of
whole arrangement of different um uh
different birds behind
um
the um
uh
um
and i think the um um
uh so i had i had i had seen somewhere i
think
that there could be arrangements where
it's not just one kind of v but where
you have little sub v's behind that v
and um uh where you have maybe a nested
pattern a sapinsky pattern or something
made up from these geese
and so i was thinking that would be a
very interesting effect and i was trying
to sort of catalog these effects and so
i asked somebody
uh actually a person who's who's a
senior person actually that company now
to um uh to look into this and and uh so
he he described it as the ultimate wild
goose chase
of looking for patterns of uh you know
these nested patterns in the flying of
wild geese we didn't find any but anyway
this whole question about how the
formation of the of the of the birds
actually works
is an interesting one there's kind of a
model usually called boyds invented by a
chap i know called craig reynolds
who who mostly invented it for for
making realistic flocks of birds for
movies like i think he worked on the
batman movie and it has a bunch of bats
in it and they're sort of flying in
formation it's a question how do you
model that and so he has this very
simple model where a bird senses only
information about neighboring birds
and then the question is what kinds of
configurations will tend to happen and
when the leading bird turns how does
that affect the other birds and you see
that in birds you also see it in the
in fish uh you know you can see these
very dramatic things with tuna and
things like that where there'll be a
huge number of fish all going in one
direction and then suddenly somebody
decides let's go a different way
and um
uh the um
the thing that um
uh
is um
um
uh the the question of of um sorry just
a second yeah
um
the um
uh
the question of of um of how that
decision is made
by this school of fish or flock of birds
and so on interesting question actually
a person i know is researching that for
sheep and she's found she has a there's
a there's a i i refer to this as a
project with legs
more particularly about let's see how
many is it maybe 200 and something legs
because that's the number of of total
number of legs of all the sheep in this
particular experimental sheep facility
somewhere in australia um where all the
sheep have been tracked and there's a
question of what determines who's the
leading sheep
and that's that's a case where you can
do it it's more difficult for birds or
fish because it's harder to put trackers
on birds and fish and so on although i
have to say i would i would have thought
on fish you could like paint qr codes or
something on the fish and have them um a
fish probably wouldn't even mind um and
then you could you know have them
trapped in a scanner or you could even
use facial recognition for the birds of
the fish i mean to us probably to me all
the fish would look the same but just
like with humans um if you know once
you're tuned into uh
different faces um you realize the faces
are slightly different so maybe somebody
could do that experiment that way of
figuring out for example if you have a
school of fish is it always the leading
fish is there an alpha fish that is
always going to be the leading one i
don't think so i think it i think with
the sheep apparently it changes around
which is the leading sheep um so kind of
the notion of they're all being led like
sheep there's a leading sheep because
otherwise the sheep wouldn't go anywhere
um and uh and so this question of what
what determines who's the leading bird
who's the leading fish
um interesting question don't know the
answer um but that's some uh but so i
think this question of okay all the
birds have decided they're gonna go in
this direction how do they make that
decision is it one bird how does it work
interesting question whether that has
lessons for us humans is an interesting
further issue
all right we should probably um uh wrap
up here
uh thank you for lots of fun questions
today and i see we've got
tons more sorry i should uh these
questions are
are
sometimes a bit complicated to answer
but um i look forward to um
uh to doing this again next week
so thanks very much and